this week as we marked one year since
the pandemic was declared it's no secret
that nursing homes
got it the worst a mixture of older
residents in limited space created a
perfect hunting ground for the deadliest
pandemic in more than 100 years
it was especially bad in the beginning
but now one year in the question is have
nursing homes made any real changes or
any attempts
to improve after the crisis we set out
to investigate she hated it
the first week she hated it there the
food
the staff members she said they weren't
nice
to the patients last october after a
fall
inside their home don eshelman's wife
sue was sent to the hospital
with a broken ankle with don working
overnights and unable to care for sue
around the clock
the couple decided the best option was
for her to do her rehab work
at the gardens at stevens a nursing home
in rural pennsylvania
and how did you meet we bet on american
online
really yes a chat room don and sue were
married in 2001.
at the time of her fall sue at 69 was
fighting kidney cancer and diabetes
but don says both were under control the
plan was for her to return home
in time for thanksgiving but not long
after she arrived
seven months after the pandemic first
began
the coronavirus swept through the
gardens at stevens
sioux along with about 80 percent of the
other residents at the home
tested positive she was eventually sent
to the hospital
wednesday they called me now this is a
wednesday before thanksgiving
they had called me and told me that they
had to put her on a ventilator
on the morning of december second don
says he got a call saying sue
should go to hospice he got a second
call that night
physician taking care of her called me
around six seven o'clock at night
told me that she's not even going to
make it to hospice what do i want
to do
make her as comfortable as possible i
don't want her to feel it
feel any pain
10 30 i get a phone call from the
hospital telling me that she had passed
sue was one of 39 patients who died from
that outbreak
two-thirds of the residents at the
nursing home
don eshelman has now begun legal action
against the gardens at stevens
he wants to know why they weren't better
prepared for a second wave
was it neglect on their part were they
short staffed
i don't know were they having their
employees come to work sick
and working i don't know
the home hasn't responded to you at all
no
they sent me a card
telling me how sorry they were for my
loss
one year and now to the worst pandemic
in a century
have nursing homes made significant
improvements
no matt yarnell is president of
sciu pennsylvania the union representing
health care workers across the
commonwealth we've had a
decades-old problem in pennsylvania
nursing homes and nursing homes around
our country but i think
you know given the covid you know crisis
it lay bear you know really decades of
problems
in the industry what's the biggest
problem i would say
the lack of staff currently nursing
homes in pennsylvania
are required to devote 2.7 hours of
personal care to each patient
in a 24-hour period a number that hasn't
changed since the 1990s
even as the population has aged less
than three hours of care
for somebody who's oftentimes totally
dependent
so they need bathed fed you know
changed toileted you know you name it
everything that we do every day to you
know sort of have basic
activities of daily living folks need
those supports and trying to figure out
how to do that
with you know in 2.7 hours of care in a
24 hour period is not very much at all
yarnell wants the amount of required
daily care to move from 2.7
to 4.1 one obstacle more staff to make
that happen means
more costs 68 of the nursing homes in
the us are
profit lower staffing levels mean higher
profits for investors
and that may have contributed to the
high levels of deaths in u.s nursing
homes from the coveted crisis
several recent studies have found that
low staffing levels were linked to large
outbreaks in individual nursing homes
another issue accountability who
actually owns the nursing homes and
how's the money spent
most of it taxpayer-funded owners listed
in public records for the gardens of
stevens
are connected to a total of over 200
other nursing homes
including the ones stan lee dawson just
retired from
you know once you get used to one set of
management
and next thing you know they make enough
money where
you know they take it out of the game
and they pass it on to the next
management company dawson worked in
nursing homes for more than 30 years
at his last one care pavilion he says
ownership passed from
one group to another three times in 16
years
when the homes got sold did the care
ever get any better
nah the the best time i can remember
from my years of working there was when
i first started
that was 2004. the
company that was running everything at
that time
was a a non-profit
the ones that came behind them
became profit-making companies did you
get the sense that owners cared about
the workers no did you get the sense
that the owners cared about
the residents somewhat
you know not like they should somewhat
you've got 60 beds
in the current your current facility how
many nursing assistants
the ratio for 60 about three how much
time does that allow you to spend with
patients individually on a daily basis
very very little
julie moore has been a nursing assistant
for more than 20 years
she works at the same nursing home in
philadelphia that dawson did
and met us before a recent shift why
won't they hire more people
they've hired people but they still
don't staff the floors correctly and
when we go to management about it they
the reason
is their their budget they're over
budget is the reason that we're getting
are you scared to speak out no not at
all
not worried about your job no
why is it so important for you to do
this because it's just not fair
the industry left to itself to correct
itself is not going to work
ultimately you're talking about money
yes but but with clear outcomes
that we're going to invest in making
sure there are enough people to do the
job and do it well
so getting to a minimum staffing level
across this country that is humane
many people already struggle big time
trying to pay for care for their parents
who are in nursing homes
you're asking them to pay more now i'm
not advocating for blank checks i'm
advocating for
you know minimum standards that are
standards that are
that are really built around care and
also transparency on where the dollars
go so we actually know what we're paying
for
have you been given any kind of timeline
don echelman has been asking to see his
wife's records from the gardens at
stevens
for three months so far to no avail
what answers do you want from the home
i want to know why
i mean it's not been the pandemic
distance started in november this
pandemic started back in march do you
think you'll get those answers
i'm hoping i get them answers that's all
i'm asking for is what happened
how did how did 39 families
lose their loved ones
so there's 38 other families out there
probably wondering the same thing i'm
wondering
what happened we reached out to the
gardens at stevens and care pavilion
multiple times for comment as well as
the owners
don ashelman is seeking damages from
they did not have
a comment and what is what is more
staffing means it means that there's
more people to do
procedures the right way it also means
the workers aren't rushed
and overworked and can pay more
attention to the patients
it seems like when that profit model is
first
that's where people start to suffer and
if they haven't learned
whether it's a pandemic or something
else there has to be better care
i think we're going to learn a lot more
in the coming years as we look at what
happened over the past year